- La vague Omicron embourbe
les urgences chinoises.
Une trentaine de malades sont
alités à l'hôpital de la ville
de Xi'an.
"Ce patient est encore
dans un état grave après
un passage aux soins intensifs",
souligne ce médecin.
À Wuhaù tout a commencé
fin 2019, les files s'allongent
à l'hôpital aux abords duquel
on érige de nouvelles salles
de quarantaine.
Lnfnfnfnfinement isole
de plus en plus la Chine
sur la scène internationale.
L'Australie est la dernière en
date à imposer des restrictionst
de Chine.
Ottawa a annoncé samedi
les voyageurs en provenance de
Chine devront présenter un test
négatif avant le décollage
dès le 5 janvier, une décision
motivée par le man d d d données
épidémiologiques.
Dre CÉCILE TREMBLAY,
microb.-infectiologue, CHUM
- C'est pas nécessairement
pour avoir uctctctct majeur
sur la transmission de la COVID
au Canada, mais c'est surtout
pour prévenir l'émergence...
l'importation de nouveaux
tststststs.
- "La Chine traverse
une période difficile",
îîîîît le président chinois.
L'abandon de la politique
zéro COVID en décembre
devait permettre la réouverture
de son économie. Mais le Fondsmt
que cette flambée des cas vienne
freiner la croissance chinoise
et mondiale pendant
quelques mois.
LOIC TASSÉ, chargé de cours,
Dép. de science politique, UdeM
- Les gens von d d d d davantage
chez eux, vont être davantage
malades, donc il faut s'attendre
à ce que, dans les prochaines
semaines, si c'est pas
les momomomomomois,
l'économie ralentisse.
- Dans un rare geste
d'ouverture, Taïwan tend la main
à Pékin pour combattre la vaguee
menace militaire chinoise.
La présidente taïwanaise
justifie son offre sur la base
de préoccupations humanitaires
pour aider plus de gtitititititr
de la pandémie et ainsi avoir
une nouvelle année en santé et
en sécurité.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hugues,
Radio-Canadl.l.l.l.l.